ce sont des images horribles bien
évidemment euh qui ont pas de de place
euh dans un cadre sportive ou dans une
enceinte sportive ou même dans la vie
euh de tous les jours qui ont
[Musique]
pas malheureusement euh la sphère
sportive et en particulier le le
football qui est un sport très populaire
il est le reflet de notre société je
vais pas vous dire qu'il n'y a pas ceci
qu'il n'y a pas cela on retrouve
exactement les mêmes problèmes qu'on
peut avoir dans la société avec
évidemment en plus une résonance
médiatique en ce qui concerne le
football qui a un impact beaucoup plus
euh important le stade un stade de foot
c'est un lieu ça doit être un lieu
familial et où les familles et les
enfants en particulier euh doiv avoir la
la tranquillité la sérénité la sécurité
de pouvoir y venir pour
euh voir un spectacle quand ça arrive
avec je vous le
répète un impact
médiatique aussi important qu'un match
du dimanche soir entre deux équipes
prestigieuses de du championnat de
France ben
forcément ça prend beaucoup de place je
sais pas pour
minimiser ce qui s'est passé c'est c'est
inacceptable et faire en sorte que ça ça
n'arrive plus et quel est votre partage
votre regard plutôt sur le partage des
responsabilités
entre l'Association des supporters la la
Ligue de foot le ministère je vais pas
dire c'est plus la faute de l'un ou de
l'autre tous tous toutes ces C ces
domaines là doivent réunir leurs forces
pour faire en sorte que que que ça
n'arrive plus ça passe par quoi
certainement de la prévention
certainement des sanctions lourdes qui
amènent peut-être ces personneslà même
si je suis pas sûr que ceux qui font de
tels actes ont la capacité de réfléchir
mais au moins
de de faire en sorte
que voilà il y a il y a des dans la vie
de tous les jours dans la société il y a
pas à avir ça et dans dans une enceinte
sportive euh euh non plus